>> WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON.
TONIGHT AMERICA'S LONGEST WAR
ENDED TODAY.
AFTER NEARLY 20 YEARS THE FINAL
U.S. MILITARY AIRCRAFT LIFTED
OFF OF AFGANISTAN.
GENERAL McKENZIE OVERSAW THIS
WAR.
HERE WAS HIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> I'M HERE TO A POUNCE THE
COMPLETION OF OUR WITH DRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN AND THE END OF THE
MILITARY MISSION TO EVACUATE
AMERICAN CITIZENS, THIRD COUNTRY
NATIONALS AND VULNERABLE
AFGHANS.
THE LAST C-17 LIST IT DID OFF ON
AUGUST 30th THIS AFTERNOON AT
3:29 P.M. EAST COAST TIME.
THE LAST MANNED AIRCRAFT IS
CHEERING THE AIRSPACE ABOVE
AFGHANISTAN.
>> WE GOT EVERYONE OUT AND WE'RE
DONE.
A POIGNANT MOMENT.
OVER 4000 AMERICANS DIED IN
AFGHANISTAN OVER TWO DECADES.
LAST WEEK ENLISTED MARINES WHO
WERE INFANTS WHAT TROOPS FIRST
ARRIVED IN THE COUNTRY.
FINALLY AFTER DECADES IT'S DONE.
IS IT DONE.
JUST MOMENTS AFTER THE CLIP YOU
JUST SAW, WE LEFT AFGHANISTAN
FOR GOOD GENERAL McKENZIE SAID
ACTUALLY NOT ALL OF US DID
LEAVE.
THERE ARE STILL AMERICANS
TRAPPED IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY LEFT
THEM BEHIND.
WATCH.
>> WE KNOW AMERICAN CITIZENS
CAME OUT ON THE LAST, WHAT WE
CALL THE JOINT TACTICAL
FILTRATION, THE LAST FIVE JETS
TO LEAVE.
WE MAINTAINED BRINGING THEM IN
IMMEDIATELY BEFORE DEPARTURE.
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO BRING ANY
AMERICANS OUT.
THAT ENDED ABOUT 12 HOURS BEFORE
OUR EXIT.
WE CONTINUED THE OUTREACH AND
PREPARED TO BRING THEM TO THE
LAST MINUTE.
NONE MADE IT TO THE AIRPORT TO
BE ACCOMMODATED.
>> NONE OF THEM MADE IT TO THE
AIRPORT.
SO THAT ANSWERS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
IN THE PAST WEEK YOU MAY OF
WONDERED ABOUT THE LARGE AND
UNKNOWN NUMBER OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS YOU READ ABOUT THAT ARE
STILL STUCK IN AFGHANISTAN.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE.
MAYBE THEY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE.
MAYBE THAT'S THE CONCLUSION YOU
HAVE COME TO OR WE DON'T OWE
THEM ANYTHING.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO BELIEVE
THAT. VERY NICE.
WE CAN'T BELIEVE IT WE LEARNED
FROM THE COMMANDER OF AMERICAN
TROOPS IN THE REGION THAT SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE, OUR COUNTRY
MEN, FELLOW AMERICANS, ARE
TRAPPED IN A NATION CONTROLLED
BY THE TALIBAN.
THESE AMERICANS TRIED TO FLEE.
IT WAS TOO CHAOTIC AND
DANGEROUS.
AS GENERAL McKENZIE PUT IT
THEY DIDN'T GET TO THE AIRPORT
IN TIME AND THE MILITARY LEFT.
TOUGH.
CALL US IF YOU MAKE IT TO TAMPA.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
GENERAL McKENZIE JUST ADMITTED
THIS IN PUBLIC.
THE REPORTERS IN THE BRIEFING
ROOM THINK IT'S NORMAL.
A PENTAGON BRIEFING.
THERE IS NOTHING NORMAL ABOUT
THIS, NOT IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S APPALLING ON EVERY LEVEL.
IT'S THE DEFINITION OF
DISHONORABLE.
WHAT'S THE IMPORTANT OF HAVING A
MILITARY THAT DOESN'T BOTHER TO
RESCUE IT'S OWN CITIZENS?
WHY DO WE HAVE AN ARMY?
THE GUNS, HELICOPTERS, MISSILE
SYSTEMS?
ISN'T THE POINT OF IT TO PROTECT
AMERICANS.
APPARENTLY THERE IS ANOTHER
PURPOSE IN THE VIEW OF THE MAN
OVERSEEING THE MILITARY CENTRAL
COMMAND.
THOSE TRAPPED AMERICANS ARE NO
LONGER OUR PROBLEM GENERAL
McKENZIE EXPLAINED.
WE WILL LET THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HANDLE WITH THAT.
WITH THAT, PART TIME SECRETARY
OF STATE TONY BLINKEN TOOK THE
PODIUM.
YES IT'S BEEN CONFIRMED MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN ABANDONED IN AFGHANISTAN
AND DESPERATE TO GET OUT NO.
, WE HAVE NO ACTUAL WAY TO
GUARANTEE THEIR SAFE PASSAGE.
THE MILITARY IS GONE.
NO PROBLEM THE MEDIEVALNESS THAT
RUNS THE COUNTRY HAS IT UNDER
CONTROL.
THE TALIBAN HAS GIVEN US THEIR
WORD AMERICAN CITIZENS WILL BE
FINE WITH.
THAT TONY BLINKEN TOOK THE
STAGE, NO QUESTIONS.
NOWHERE DID JOE BIDEN APPEAR
THEN OR ANYTIME TODAY TO EXPLAIN
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES APPEARS TO BE MISSING
AGAIN.
YOU CAN SEE CLEARLY WE'RE
WATCHING A PIVOT POINT IN OUR
HISTORY.
THE MOST OBVIOUS CASUALTY APART
FROM THE 13 DEAD SERVICE MEN
LAST WEEK IS -- DIMINISHED.
THERE WILL BE HUGE CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS MOMENT.
WILL YOU SEE THEM BOTH IN THE
NEAR TERM AND GENERATIONS GOING
FORWARD.
FOR NOW IT'S WORTH ANSWERING A
SIMPLE QUESTION WHO IS TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS?
WHO IS PAYING FOR THE DISASTER
WE'RE WATCHING?
NOT SO LONG AGO THAT WOULD OF
BEEN AN EASY QUESTION TO ANSWER,
OUR LEADERS PAY THE PRICE.
UNTIL RECENTLY THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE UNDERSTOOD LEADERSHIP
COMES WITH OBLIGATIONS NOT JUST
PRIVILEGES.
IF YOU MAKE BIG DECISIONS YOU
HAVE TO SUFFER IF THEY GO WRONG.
IN THE SPRINGING OF 1912 EDWARD
SMITH RAN HIS SHIP NO AP ICEBERG
IN THE NORTH ATLANTIC.
AS IT WENT DOWN SMITH DIDN'T
BLAME CLIMATE CHANGE FOR THE
DISASTER.
INSTEAD HE WEPT TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE OCEAN AND PEOPLE APPLAUDED.
IT WAS EXPECTED.
HE WAS IN CHARGE.
HE STAYED UNTIL THE END.
SO WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THIS.
WHO IS PAYING FOR IT?
OVERTIME AN ENTIRE CLASS OF FORM
POLICY EXPERTS AND POLITICAL
LEADERS ARE RESPONSIBLE.
THEY WATCHED FOR TWENTY YEARS AS
AFGHANISTAN TURNED TO A
POINTLESS MESS.
DAMAGE BEYOND REPAIR AND THEY
LIED ABOUT IT REPEATEDLY.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
LIZ CHENEY COMES TO PHOEUPD.
THERE ARE MANY, MANY LIKE HER.
THEN THERE ARE THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT HAS
HAPPENED THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
A PULLOUT THAT COULDN'T OF BEEN
MORE INEPTLY MANAGED THAN IF YOU
PLANNED TO SCREW IT UP.
JOE BOYD EN AND HIS LIEUTENANTS.
WHAT IS THEIR PUNISHMENT?
HOW MANY HAVE FIRED.
HOW MANY HAVE RESIGNED?
HOW MANY HAVE APOLOGIZED?
SO OUR KNOWLEDGE NONE.
NOT ONE.
I FACT SO FAR AS WE CAN TELL THE
ONLY MILITARY LEADER TO SUFFER
SO FAR FOR THIS DISASTER IS A
MARINE CORP LIEUTENANT COLONEL
CALLED STEW SHELLER.
HE DIDN'T PLAN TO A BEEN DON THE
AIR BASE.
SHELLER'S CRIME WAS POSTING THIS
VIDEO ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> IF A BATTALION COMMANDER HAS
A COMPLAINT, BOOM FIRED.
WE HAVE A SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
TESTIFYING IN MAY THAT THE
AFGHAN FORCES CAN WITHSTAND THE
ADVANCE.
WE HAVE THOSE ADVISING MILITARY
POLICY.
A MARINE COMBAT ANT COMMANDER,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE IS A
POSE TO ADVICE.
I'M NOT SAYING WE HAVE TO BE IN
AFGHANISTAN FOREVER.
I'M SAYING DID ANY OF YOU THROW
YOUR RANK ON THE TABLE AND SAY
IT'S A BAD IDEA TO ABANDON THE
AIR BASE BEFORE EVACUATING
EVERYONE.
>> THIS IS A DISASTER.
THAT IS OBVIOUS.
THE DISASTER IS A RESULT OF
SERIES OF BAD DECISIONS BY
PEOPLES NAMES WE KNOW.
HAVE THOSE PEOPLE BEEN PUNISHED,
EXPLAIN THEMSELVES, OR
APOLOGIZE?
THAT'S THE QUESTION THAT STU
SCHELLER ASKED.
FOR ASKING HE WAS RELIEVED OF
HIS COMMAND.
HE IS RESIGNING.
HE HAS THREE YEARS UNTIL
RETIREMENT AND THE PENSION THAT
COMES WITH IT HE IS LEAVING.
THIS IS WHY.
>> ALL I ASKED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY OF MY SENIOR
LEADERS WHEN THERE ARE CLEAR
OBVIOUS MISTAKES MADE.
I'M NOT SAYING WE CAN TAKE BACK
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE.
ALL I ASKED FOR WAS
ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR PEOPLE TO COMMENT ON WHAT I
SAID, TO SAY YES, MISTAKES WERE
MADE.
I THINK THEM ACCEPTING
ACCOUNTABILITY WOULD DO MORE FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS WITH PTSD THAN A
TRANSPARENT MESSAGE.
I HAVE NOT RECEIVED THAT.
>> YA.
I MEAN THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
DIED IN AFGHANISTAN.
TENS OF THOUSANDS, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS WERE PERMANENTLY
DAMAGED AFTER 20 YEARS.
THE EXIT DIMINISHES OUR COUNTRY
PERMANENTLY.
WHO DID THAT?
WHY HAVEN'T THEY APOLOGIZED?
IT'S A REALLY SIMPLE QUESTION.
FOR ASKING IT SCHELLER WAS
RELIEVED OF COMMAND.
INSTEAD OF TAKING ANY FORM OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS DISASTER
THAT THEY CAUSED THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING THE
OPPOSITE.
BRAGGING IN PUBLIC WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE, WHAT A GREAT JOB
THEY HAVE DONE.
JOE BIDEN'S FLACK HAS ANNOUNCED
THEY DON'T PLAN ON PUNISHING
ANYONE FOR WHAT WE'RE WATCHING
NOW.
NO ONE.
>> DOES HE BELIEVE HE WAS GIVEN
BAD ADVICE, WILL HE ASK FOR
RESIGNATIONS FROM HIS GENERALS
GIVEN THE HIGH COST OF AMERICAN
AND AFGHAN LIVES?
>> NO TO BOTH OF THOSE
QUESTIONS.
>> SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
POSITION HAS NOT CHANGED IN THE
FACE OF ALL OF THE EVIDENCE
WE'RE WATCHING ON TELEVISION.
THEY'RE TELLING YOU THEY DID AS
WELL AS THEY COULD OF DONE.
JOE BIDEN SAID THAT FIRST AUGUSE
BOMBING IN KABUL.
RECENT AS TODAY THE PENTAGON'S
TOP SPOKES PERSON SAID IT TODAY.
WATCH JOHN KIRBY EXPLAIN THERE
WAS NO WAY TO PREDICT THE AFGHAN
PRESIDENT WOULD SUDDENLY ABANDON
THE COUNTRY TO THE TALIBAN.
>> OUR EXPECTATION WAS THAT THE
AFGHANI GOVERNMENT WOULD STAY IN
PLACE.
NOBODY WOULD OF IMAGINED HOW
QUICKLY THE GOVERNMENT JUST
DISSIPATED ALMOST OVER NIGHT.
THERE WAS NO WAY TO PREDICT
THAT.
>> WE COULD SPEND THE REST OF
THE SHOW.
REST OF THE WEEK, REST OF THE
YEAR UNTIL NEW YEAR'S DAY GOING
THROUGH EACH LIE THEY'RE TELLING
YOU AND BATTING IT DOWN.
THESE ARE FLIMSY LIES.
WE WON'T DO THAT, IT WOULD GIVE
EVERYONE A HEADACHE.
LET'S TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THIS
ONE.
"THERE WAS SIMPLY NO WAY TO
PREDICT THE THE PRESIDENT OF
AFGHANISTAN WAS GOING TO FOLD
AND RUN AWAY."
IF YOU WANT A SENSE HOW
LUDICROUS THAT STATEMENT IS AND
WHAT A LIE IT IS CONSIDER WHAT
OUR GOVERNMENT KNEW ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT OF AFGHANISTAN.
A WORDING TO THE WASHINGTON POST
THEY DIDN'T KNOW HE FLED
AFGHANISTAN UNTIL IT WAS ON
TELEVISION.
THEY HAD NO IDEA.
"U.S. OFFICIALS WERE SURPRISED
AS ANYONE.
OFFICIALS EXPECTED HIM TO STAY
FOR A ORDERLY TRANSMISSION.
-- ABOUT HIS DEPARTURE.
NOWHERE DID GHANI CONTACT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT PIECING TOGETHER
THE MOVEMENT FROM RUMOR AND
MEDIA REPORTS ."
OUR INTEL AGENCIES RECEIVED A
COMBINED $85 BILLION LAST YEAR
ALONE IN FEDERAL TAX DOLLARS.
THAT'S MORE MONEY THAN RUSSIA,
GERMANY, AND THE UK SPEND ON
THEIR ENTIRE ANNUAL MILITARY
BASIS.
FOR ALL OF THAT MONEY OUR
GENERAL AND SPIES WERE CONFIDENT
THAT GHANI WOULD STICK AROUND
FOR A "ORDERLY TRANSITION."
NO WAY TO PREDICT OTHERWISE.
MEANWHILE NO ONE COULD SAY WHERE
GHANI WAS.
THEY HAD NO IDEA OUR AUTHORITIES
SAY HAVE NO PROBLEM FINDING A
MIDDLE AEUPLGD WOMEN WAVING A
FLAG AT THE CAPITOL BUILDING BUT
CAN'T FIND THE PRESIDENT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
THAT DOESN'T SAY WE'RE
COMPLETELY IN THE DARK.
BEFORE KABUL FELL IT WAS EVIDENT
GHANI WAS NOT INTERESTED.
AS TALIBAN SEIZED KEY
TERRITORIES OF AH KWAPB STAN
STKPW-RBGS HANI WAS TRANS FIXED
BY A NEW GOVERNMENT PAYMENT
SYSTEM SLATED TO ROLL OUT SOON.
EVEN AS A CASCADE OF PREVENTIAL
CAPITOLS FELL GHANI APPEARED
DISTRACTED.
"GHANI WOULD WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE DIGITIZATION OF THE ECONOMY
NOT THE DIRE THREAT."
KEEP IN MIND GHANI NO BACKGROUND
IN RELEVANT DISCIPLINE.
HE WAS A COLLEGE PROFESSOR
WORKING AT JOHN HOPKINS.
WE PICKED A COMPLETELY
INCOMPETENT TOOL FROM AMERICAN
ACADEMIA THEN AN ACTUAL AFGHAN
THAT COULD RUN THE COUNTRY.
OF COURSE WE DID, TONY BLINKEN
LIKED HIM.
PEOPLE LIKE TONY BLINKEN LIKED
HIM.
SO THE PERSONAL BEHAVIOR
REPORTEDLY RAISED RED FLAGS WITH
U.S. OFFICIALS INCLUDING FRANK
McKENZIE, HEAD OF CENTRAL
COMMAND.
McKENZIE WAS MYSTIFIED BY
GHANI'S BEHAVIOR.
DID ANYONE IN THE PENTAGON DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT?
OF COURSE THEY DIDN'T.
NOTHING.
THEY PRESENTED EVERYTHING WAS
FINE.
THEY'RE DUMB.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT DIDN'T
REACH OUT TO SEE WHAT HE WAS
DOING.
INSTEAD THEY WORKED TO GET OTHER
COUNTRIES TO SIGN A STATEMENT TO
SEND TO THE TALIBAN URGING THEM
TO LET AMERICANS OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
ULTIMATELY THE STATEMENT WAS
SIGNED BY MILITARY POWER HOUSES
LIKE HAITI, DEMOCRATIC OF CONGA.
THAT'S WHAT THEY FEEL IS
SIGNIFICANT.
A STUPID DOCUMENT THAT MEANS
NOTHING.
THESE ARE CHILDREN.
NO ONE IS APOLOGIZING FOR IT.
THEY WON'T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE
SCREWING UP.
THEY'RE NOT HAVING A MOMENT OF
SELF REFLECTION.
WHY WERE THEY ON THE PHONE WITH
HAITI WHILE CITIZENS WERE
TRAPPED IN AFGHANISTAN RAN BY
THE TALIBAN.
THEY WON'T EXPLAIN WHY THEY PUT
THE SAFETY OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
IN THE HANDS OF A PRESIDENT WHO
DIDN'T CARE ENOUGH TO STICK
AROUND.
THAT PRESIDENT, GHANI, IS NOT
APOLOGIZING.
HE WAS TRAINED BY THE U.S.
HE HAS FLED CLAIMING TO BE A
HERO LEAVING HIS COUNTRY TO
AVOID MORE BLOODSHED RATHER THAN
WHAT HE CLEARLY S A COWARD.
HIS KIDS, AMERICANS OF COURSE
WITH U.S. PASSPORTS LIVING ON
MILLION DAR DOLLAR PROPERTIES
DEMANDING THIS COUNTRY ACCEPT AS
MANY AFGHAN REFUGEES AS
POSSIBLE.
HIS SON WORKED FOR PETE ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
OUR BRAIN DEAD RULING CLASS
CHOSE SOMEONE JUST LIKE THEM.
OF COURSE THEY DID.
SUDDENLY A LOT OF WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN THE PAST 20 YEARS IN
AFGHANISTAN, PARTICULARLY THE
LAST FOUR MONTHS MAKES SENSE.
THE EXPERTS TOOK TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO INSTALL PEOPLE IN
AFGHANISTAN AS CLUE LESS AS THEY
ARE.
REMEMBER IT WAS IN JUNE U.S.
INTELLIGENCE PREDICT THE THE
GHANI GOVERNMENT WOULD REMAIN
INTACT FOR SIX MONTHS.
AS RECENTLY AS THIS MONTH THEY
HAD NO EVIDENCE THE TALIBAN
WOULD TAKE OVER AFGHANISTAN
QUICKLY.
>> THERE WAS NOTHING THAT I OR
ANYONE ELSE SAW THAT INDICATED A
COLLAPSE OF THIS ARMY AND THIS
GOVERNMENT IN ELEVEN DAYS.
>> SO THEY BELIEVE THAT. THEY
ACTUALLY BELIEVED IT.
BECAUSE THE IN COMPETENCE AROUND
THEM REPEATED IT LIKE IT WAS
TRUE AND THEY BOUGHT IT.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
THE PENTAGON A MAN DONNED THE
AIR BASE.
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN A MUCH
EASIER PLACE TO SECURE THAN AN
AIRPORT.
COMMERCIAL AIRPORT IN THE
CAPITOL CITY.
SENT THINK THEY WOULD NEED
BAGRAM.
THEY HAD CONFIDENCE IN GHANI.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
APPARENTLY TURNED DOWN THE
TALIBAN'S OFFER AND THOUGHT THEY
WOULD HAVE FAR MORE TIME THAN
THEY TK-PLT.
>> ON THE TACTICAL DECISION ON
WHICH IS THE RIGHT AIRPORT FOR
AN EVACUATION OF COURSE ANY
RESPONSIBLE PRESIDENT WOULD GIVE
SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT TO THE ADVICE
OF COMMANDERS ON THE GROUND.
THEIR ADVICE WAS TO CLOSE BAGRAM
AND FOCUS ON KABUL.
>> CLOSE BAGRAM AND FOCUS ON KA
KABUL.
WE DID THAT AND NOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE DEAD.
NOBODY HAS APOLOGIZED.
IF YOU CATCH YOUR KID DOING
SOMETHING WRONG YOU DON'T REST
UNTIL THEY APOLOGIZE.
THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
FIXING A PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT JUST PRACTICALLY
IMPORTANT.
IT'S SPIRITUALLY IMPORTANT.
ADMIT YOU ARE WRONG.
THEY WON'T.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT YOU THINK.
SO TO THIS MOMENT THE ONLY
PERSON WHO HAS BEEN PUNISHED FOR
THE TERRIBLE DECISIONS, ONE
MARINE CORP OFFICER WHO
CRITICIZED THE DECISIONS.
THIS CAN'T GO ON.
WHEN LEADERS REFUSE TO HOLD
THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE OVERTIME
PEOPLE REVOLT.
THAT HAPPENS.
WE NEED TO CHANGE COURSE
IMMEDIATELY AND START
ACKNOWLEDGING OUR MISTAKES.
THE PEOPL